[Music]
what up ernie
what up how are you boss painting away
a little blunt man and chronic colors
today and there he is himself look at it
turn around everybody
it's michael zapp sick what's up boys
i don't want to say hi to the camera
mike's mike's part of the part of the
whole game
no no this is all ernie yeah mike's got
some good ideas
[ __ ] awesome this is the entrance
into the tell him steve dave
somewhat theater um
and in there in the back you can see the
green screen that's going to be where
they're going to film all the skits and
stuff
all we're going to do now is get the
floors in here get some uh retail stuff
in here some counters for walt
ride it's gonna look good man it feels
real good
what do you want behind you so pick and
choose wisely
you should be
explain the layout of this new stash
just a bit uh
well over here obviously we come in we
walk through we walk through the doors
over here
coming to the staff to the right is
going to be a nice long
12 foot counter that's going to wrap
around kind of
batman-esque in colors inside there
they're looking to put mr tusk so he's a
little bit more accessible
this whole wall over here is going to be
all your comics on the slat
artwork and displays up top
it's probably looking to be the base
color a little bit purple
ties in with the blunt man and chronic
colors that we're doing in the building
not to mention it's also going to tie
into our movies display that we're doing
here
and then the floor we're not sure about
the floor yet but i think we're uh
we're gonna do something pretty cool um
jazz it up a little bit because this
building is actually pretty old right
like this is the original floor
yeah this is the original floor from the
early 1900s this was a shoe store called
miles shoe store
way back in the day and uh we tried
bringing the original floor back but
it's kind of
it's kind of too far gone but uh we're
gonna
put something over and make it really
cool so i noticed you also improved upon
uh the ceiling yeah well yeah finally we
started getting our drop ceiling in
and uh we have to leave a few drop
ceilings out so when we get our final
inspections
they can check out our rough electric
our fire wire that's all up there uh
make sure that everything is copacetic
uh that we pass code
but that was all done and we're waiting
on inspections for that
so uh once that's done it'll all be uh
tidied up
closed in and then we're ready to rock
and roll so we'll see you guys next time
on
project stash we can rebuild it baby
we can do it no problem thank you i'll
see you later
[Music]
you